i never wash my hands any time
regardless me neither i go pee it's my
dick i don't wash my hands before or
after ever
not and i stand by that me too and i
never will as a matter of fact i'll go
one further when i take a number two i
don't wash my hands yes you do [ __ ] you
can't even say that with a straight face
you ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea what you're
saying gang
[Laughter]
i can't figure out is he keto or not
would you say he got stung by a bee
he's swelling he looks like my agent he
looks like my agent to a d
doesn't he
no does he have an allergic reaction to
something he does look like he has a
smaller face yeah it looks like he had a
smaller face he just he ate something
and he's like i need might just be pen
we just got done working out yeah also
is it uh
1999 with that [ __ ] that a bluetooth
european
oh come on
i know all right
what's up guys this is trevor from
chattanooga tennessee i got a debate
club for you guys today
uh guys who make tech deck videos for
instagram you know little finger
skateboards or guys who rev the [ __ ] out
of their cars all day long
because it's easier to explain that your
boyfriend's into cars and he makes
little finger skateboard videos
uh skates funny yeah i personally say
it's gonna be a car guy until he kick
flips that [ __ ]
[Music]
i'm a fan of this uh nothing uh triggers
me more than guys in cars i hate rapping
i tell myself when we go the car should
i go that that's for guys who uh don't
know you know you're totally insecure
yeah you know what's worse than the cars
though he's like [ __ ] guys with small
dicks the loud ass motorcycles too well
yeah same thing though yeah i mean no
that's horrible because it's just yeah
it's constant but you know why
motorcycles are so loud yeah
so so you hear them they're they're
perfectly i know obnoxiously loud so you
can hear them
it's still too loud yeah yeah the cars
like when when you're in the idle and
i'm like what are you doing dude they
got a lot also you didn't build the car
why are you fly when we go to the car
show and guys are like you like my
ferrari it's like you didn't build it
yeah actually pretty funny actually you
have nothing to do with it yeah you just
bought it
yeah why are you acting like this they
want to show you it's like security at
the club they're all arrogant it's like
you don't know in the club dude
oh my god this is a real thing no it's
not that is that a real [ __ ] thing
nick that's what he was talking about
what's worse
oh well this he sent in two versions one
he said who pulls more tech deck video
guys or loud car guys loud car guys
unless it's like a rice rocket wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait i don't
can i tell you something
i don't you know who is even worse in
this video i don't know but this makes
me want to leave this it's not these
idiots doing this
it's the big crowd watching
is there a crowd like there's a crowd
watching such a good point eric this
makes you want to leave planet earth
nah this is i get if tony hawk's doing
it now because he's 70. so he's like i
can't do this anymore so let me show you
what i used to do yeah it'd be great if
like i'm doing it i'm like all right
look what i can't do guys but like that
young kids who should be out doing [ __ ]
in the world bro this these videos have
six seven million views yeah they're
ironic for you dude if my son if my son
what it would scott in this but you you
know you can get a real [ __ ]
skateboarder yeah
you know you don't have to use your
fingers that's what calvin's going to do
you know what i'll tell you what i can't
wait i wonder what tricks these guys do
these guys do when they masturbate you
know the thing about this is you know
they're like
i don't like i don't like their dick
i bet there's girls watching now like oh
yeah
yeah what else can you do with your
fingers they would be disappointed
though and they'd be like i thought it
was going to be good but
no there's your tracks i would only like
this if they put little pants on their
fingers
and like little vans yeah like little
vans like there you go like if you're
going to do it oh man do it i'm in but
this is ridiculous but imagine meeting
one of you guys like the number one guy
at a bar he picked some some chick he's
like a big event tomorrow babe it's a
big event
she comes she's like this is it
like the guys oh
oh my god the rodriguez dunks too oh no
those are dope oh see now now i'm in
that's dope
oh
yeah
are you going oh he goes oh
he can move
oh this is sick
oh that's the [ __ ] bro this is
ridiculous oh calvin would love this
[ __ ] yeah so my kid is that even about
the skateboard anymore
i don't want my son to see this
oh my god this is ridiculous i'd rather
my son watch isis beheading videos than
discovers
oh this is like oh wow but also get a
real skateboard right don't work on your
toy
right funny right everybody i want to
see him skateboard in the pants oh he's
going to he's just got to hook this
board up bro he's got to set it up nick
just
in this video he's down
oh dude
oh look he's going to the park now
you're crazed some fat kid didn't invent
this who's like man [ __ ] your
skateboards check this yeah this would
make more sense to me if it was just
like or if it was like you know special
needs kids or like you know people that
can't
people that can't do certain things then
i would get it be like but like you're i
i i'm escaping what i can't do
lost his legs like this is my new thing
man it's my passion right oh that's cool
man right but them but do the real thing
the fact that there's people watching is
what like i guess people that watch
anything i mean look they're watching us
you know people watch anything
it's the king and the sting back up in
this thing
[Music]
brandon chris and theo what you mean you
know